you'll notice that sooner or later it
will
it it has you in its grips to the point
where you're like where it'll do
something
that is um so enthralling that
it won't leave your memory that you
won't you just
you won't forget it it just won't go
away
do you ever envision your script sitting
in a pile on someone's desk or maybe
in their study on a weekend and think
what's going to make mine stand out here
what chance do i have yeah absolutely
the way i look at that
you know this is at the risk of sounding
redundant is you know i've talked about
the whole
aspect of the voice but you know the
the voice is one thing but you know i
in in my case i'm confident in my voice
now you go on you move on to that other
word which is confidence
so with that with with with confidence
um you what you
want to do when you have like a polished
sample
or a polish spec script um
um that that you're submitting or
or somebody's reading or it doesn't
matter who's reading it it really
doesn't because
once you're once you are um
mincing um what eyes are on your script
you're in trouble right there
you you you need to convince anybody and
anyone
that what you have is is worth seeing
turned into a movie so what that means
is you either you have either have to um
knock them in the head um um punch them
in the gut
or kick them in the balls and and and
and
and that's something that you have to be
doing
in the narrative of your story
um and and if you know you are doing
that
with your story you know you'll notice
what i'm saying here is like
it's not just your script it's your
story
because your script is a artifice
that starts to make someone um believe
that there are reading a
a story a a a
a potential movie something that they
get immersed in
that they get lost in now if you're not
taking them to that place if you're not
creating that illusion
with the words that you mind to do it
then you've lost from the get-go
from the beginning so
that's if anything is what i imagine if
somebody has my
uh my script in a pile over the weekend
and the thing is that what what i
enjoy about that thought or that that
metaphor um is that
you know i i've you know had experience
with running the gauntlet of that
metaphor
is like um um
is like you know you you know when you
like
you're like oh hey like let me give you
that
that'll get your attention boom and then
you know you know you get the call you
get the phone calls
like wow i love your love yours love
your screenplay
wow that was amazing that really hit me
i was i
i read i read 200 scripts over the last
five days you know that's
you there's nothing more that you love
to hear than that
you can look and yours got my attention
you know it's like it's like
that that is that is like that you know
that's the kind
well 200 might be a little but a bit you
know people read a lot of scripts
um in the industry and and that's
because there's a lot of stuff out there
that you got to fight to get through
um to um to to
have people recognize your talent as a
storyteller
so you like i said you know you gotta
whack them in the head
you know um punch them in the gut or
kick them in the balls
so yeah okay can you
can you give me an example of a movie
that
is going to whack them or kick them in
the nether region that
that they never read sorry in case it's
you know pg-13 whatever i'm censoring
myself
can you give me an example of a movie
that if i saw an opening
it would do that and if that was the
script i was reading i would be
feeling that to one degree or another
okay um let me see
um one that i can think of well
you know um just because we were just
discussing it um
um um michael clayton is great because
you have
you have a lawyer who takes off his
clothes during a death position
you know immediately i'm like okay i'm
in
it doesn't happen every day you know
i'm in you know what i mean it's like
what is this about
i want to know i'm curious you know
right
okay that works so like you know that's
one
i'm always at a loss for like pulling um
examples for for some films like you
know
at the at the drop of a hat let me see
if i can
extract i can like if i go down the list
of like you know for me
of um of tony gilroy movies
is really actually not so hard with him
because like you can go
like to the bourne supremacy which is
amazing opening one of the great
openings
where like um you know um there was a
chase um
and um they they find where born
is um where he's hiding out um with his
girlfriend and his girlfriend
dies in the first the first
10 minutes i think of the film and i'm
like
and you're like the stakes are so high
at that point
um it's this is you know this is what
you have to do
with your storytelling most of the time
now now what i mean by that
when i say like um uh um
um you know wax them in the head punch
someone in the gut
or kick them in the nether region so to
speak
um is is is that it can be a slow burn
too it doesn't have to be um immediate
if it's a slow burn in it
and it hooks you you'll notice that
sooner or later
it will it it has you in its grips to
the point
where you're like where it'll do
something
that is um so enthralling that
it won't leave your memory that you
won't
you just you won't forget it it just
won't go away
you know and and and that is what you're
doing with storytelling if you if you
are under the um
if you are under the notion or the idea
or the
the misconception that you are
you are trying to
express um something that you feel
is um well
for lack of a better term you know i i
think that that
that some writers new writers um they
get caught up in
these masturbatory exercises of
emulating you know certain um other
um writers and and filmmakers they
really admire
and it's just an indulgence because
they're just trying to piece together
the things that they
that they like thinking that that's
going to make an
impression on the reader but that is not
going to do it you know what's going to
make the impression
is someone getting lost in what you're
telling them you know and and
and the way that you tell them um tell
them it
um and if you get if you
get caught up in those kind of details
you're gonna you're gonna be in trouble
you know
you're not you're people are going to
get bored and they're going to shut your
script
because what really happens with readers
what really happens
with executives and producers and people
that have
very busy schedules is they take
five pages of your script and they read
it and then they put it down
if it doesn't hook them
you'll be lucky actually if you get five
pages
you'll be lucky so those five pages
whatever you're doing in those five
pages whether it's the way you've
written that description
whether the way it's the way that you've
delineated
um those characters whether
it's it's a passage of dialogue
they have to they they have to be firing
on all cylinders or
it's like so-and-so
becomes a drink coaster yeah next
next next yeah
that's the way it works
can you give me an example and i'm
trying to come up with a euphemism for
the term that you use but
of of a writer who's stroking their own
ego a master of their domain as you
so well they're they're bad writers you
know it's
it's like you you can't you can't take
on you can't take on someone
someone who is successful because more
than likely they're doing something
right
do you know what i'm saying so so so
uh you you can't i i i can't cast
dispersions against
anybody that's successful at what
they're doing because they're doing
something right to you and to get
something to get
people's attention so um
it's you know it's it's it's simply
just that it's like keep
keep people turning the page you know
and um and and
and tell your story but you gotta you
gotta keep them excited
or they'll throw it away sometimes i've
gotten into the situation
and this happens a lot where um
where someone will say send me send me a
couple of screenplays
send me send me three free scripts or
something like that
right now you have to be
smart about that all right
because when you do that
you go like well maybe maybe they like
this
maybe or maybe they won't like that and
maybe they'll like that
over here all right so you send it
and the and and sometimes they'll go you
know what
i i i was reading i've been reading uh
pile of scripts and
you know um one of your scripts you know
it's
i just didn't really connect it but the
other one oh
oh because you you you know what you're
doing that's the confidence i'm
i'm talking about you know what you're
doing it's like well maybe they're not
this is not the sort of thing that
they're that they're in
that that that's their oath but maybe
this over is like that's a little
conversely on the other side of that of
this kind of subject matter
so so that's what the
game is that's what the the strategy is
behind the game the game is getting them
hooked
just as you would be hooked if you were
in the theater
watching the story all right
because if it reaches that stage like we
said if you're we're successful to get
to that point
then you must be doing something right
you know unless we do even even the
even the the the
the more lackluster stories
still are stories
you